hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round 8 of this
year's Tata still Masters Edition it is
Richard Rapport versus pragnananda and
it's a really really wild game with some
very cool moves you guys will have a
very nice positive video moment
um uh brush up on your this time
defensive skills uh because the position
is just remarkable uh so let's dive
straight into it and see what happened
here so rapport with the white pieces
opens with E4 we have E5 Knight to F3
Knight to C6 and Bishop to C4 with
Bishop the C5 and now Pawn to C3 the
main line of the Joker piano even though
we all know what the main line of the
Joker piano is but okay Knight to F6 we
have D3 D6 and now Knight B to D2 so
very standard stuff here the Joker
pianissimo variation we have A6 and
Bishop to B3 now we have castles Knight
to F1 and now Knight to E7 by Prague
with Bishop to G5 and now Knights the G
6 and here it upward mixes all of the
ideas together and just advances the
pawn to H4 and it is now already as of
move 10 then we have a completely new
game which is very very exciting stuff
as we uh see the The Joker piano and the
Joker pianissimo pretty much every other
game and here we have Rook to E8 it's a
very nice move by Prague because the
problem with a move like H5 usually when
you see H4 uh black will just reply with
H5 stop any and all pawn pushing but the
problem is you no longer have H6 and
this uh pin on the Knight here will
remain for a very long time let's ignite
the G3 Bishop to G4 and now even Queen
to D2 but the problem is uh you can
never push D5 the the Knight here is a
very important piece controlling the D5
square but now with the the bishop just
spinning the Knight and the which you no
longer having the option of playing H6
this is just a very bad for black
uh so that's why after age four product
just goes for Rook to E8 we have H5 now
challenging the Knight Knight the F4 and
now Knight to G3 allowing proc to
capture the G2 Pawn but this is not the
the best way to go I will just show you
what happens because it looks like it's
a free Pawn the problem is if Knight
captures King F1 and just Knight to F4
seems like you snatched upon you just go
back with the Knight all of a sudden uh
sorry you are this met with a move like
Pawn to H6 and now let's say G6 Pawn to
D4 and this Knight is now a very a very
uh weekly plate P placed piece because
now let's say Bishop to B6 just D
captures an E5 and now this Knight is
weak as well if you capture uh just
Queen captures Queen and nothing is
defending this Knight but you I mean uh
Black's entire position just falls apart
you really have nothing better than the
the capsule it's the captors captures
the bishop captures and F6 and now even
Bishop to H3 check which could be a bit
dangerous is met with Rook captures on
H3 and after night cap procedure is
gonna capture on E5 and Black's position
is uh well pretty much resigns so after
Knight the G3 we have H6 now chasing
away the bishop Bishop captures an F4 we
have e captures an F4
and now Knight the E2 going after the
the F4 Pawn Knights the G4 you could
also Play Bishop to G4 proxies I'll
write a deal with the the F uh two Pawn
First sort of checking if Robert will
Castle uh King side and if you Castle
then maybe the H5 Pawn will be will be
very weak then maybe Prague will get
some attacking chances so rapid goes
Rook to F1 even though castling actually
is fine in this position and not Knight
back to F6 just going after the H5 pawn
queen to C2 and now Bishop to G4 you can
always capture on H5 there's no need to
rush her with Queen side castles and now
Bishop to A7 not allowing the D4 push to
come with Tempo and also Prague wants to
play c5b5 and attack the white king that
castle Queen side so Knight captures on
F4 we have C6 and now Rook Dita E1
Knight captures an H5 and now Queen to
D2 first before trading uh Knights here
we have Queen to F6 and now Knight
captures on H5 with Bishop captures and
now Rook the H1 uh putting pressure on
that Bishop so Bishop captures an F3
process all right I will take your Pawn
G captures and queen captures and this
is where uh the fun really starts the F2
Pawn is being attacked so Rapport
defends it Rook to H2 and now you know
that a rook is coming on G1 most likely
then there will be all sorts of threats
like Wing captures and H6 for example so
proc plays King to f8 and now we have
Bishop to D1
uh this is an incredibly strong move by
Robert kicking away the queen uh because
you can't uh get rid of the queen on F3
and you really want to play F4 so Bishop
to D1 accomplishes just that Queen to F6
and now Pawn to F4 and now you no longer
have to worry about uh the df2 pawn
being a weakness and D4 E5 are coming uh
with prox King stuck on that f8 square
aligns are open in front of the black
king so there are many ways you could
continue this game but just for fun feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the absolute best way to play this
uh for black uh while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
well just the absolute best way to play
the position and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Rook a
to d8 which is much much different than
what Prague played in the game uh Prague
played King the E7 and his idea was to
bring the king over to the queen side
where it will be much safer and usually
uh such ideas uh are more than welcome
it's a very creative way of thinking and
uh I know players like uh tigran
Petrosian would uh you know uh just uh
impress Everyone by by doing these crazy
King walks where you bring the king in
in the in an open board and then you
hide it all the way to the other side of
the board but this is just uh one such
position where it does not work so I'm
just gonna show you how you should play
this and it's incredibly difficult to
play like this for example Rook 88 and
now after white continues developing of
course you want to play the bishop on
this dagger we want to play D4 E5 now B5
and now after D4 you want to play C5 and
now after E5 it's a very very dangerous
looking position let's say queen F5
Bishop to C2 attacks the queen queen to
G4 and now even D5 uh now black will
play C4 now you you can't just wait for
y to continue the attack you have to
start your own attack now B4 is coming
and if Pawn to E6 which is very nice you
will play F captures on E6 now Rook the
G2 and now after the queen moves let's
say queen H3 Bishop to G6 goes after The
Rook Rook the E7 and now after King to
B1 you will advance the pawn to B4 and
here the entire position just completely
explodes C capture some B for even
Bishop to D4 is an option because the
queen cannot capture the rook and G2
would be hanging so absolute Madness of
a position but all in all uh black
should be able to hold this if black and
continues playing actively with moves
like C3 and so on so it's a very very
cool way of of playing but Prague
decided to play even cooler he played
King the E7 but now it's uh it's a bit
dangerous for him Ponte D4 he plays King
to D7 of course he wants to hide the
king Now Pawn to E5 and now the problem
is there's just no good Square for the
queen uh whatever plate it's going to be
insufficient you can't play a move like
uh like if you put the queen on this
diagonal it's just gonna be very bad
then Rook G2 then Bishop to G4 check uh
let me just show let's say queen to G6
Rook G2 now you can play Queen F5
because the bishop just picks up the
queen and if you put the queen on H7
that the queen is basically out of the
game Bishop to G4 with check you're
going to play King C7 now captures on D6
and if captures uh Rook G to E2 and here
you resign there's no good way to
uh handle all the pressure on the e-file
and if Queen to G8 to guard your Rook
even F5 opening up this diagonal for the
queen and if Rook captures an E2 you're
just gonna play Queen captors again you
prevent Rook to E8 and now after let's
say I move like F6 because you really
need to stop Queen to E5 uh but you you
can't keep an eye on everything for
example if F6 Queen to E7 with the check
and you will get the checkmated bishop
F3 checking to C4 and now Queen to E2
will be Checkmate so uh many many uh
cool ideas here but uh not not just not
for for black so Queen to E7 the only
playable move for Prague we have rooked
the G2 now goes after the G7 Pawn Prague
defends it and now even Pawn to F5 just
blasting through if you don't capture
then of course just captures captures
and captures so proud characters on F5
but now Rook to G7 again not uh a lot of
a lot of moves for Prague E6 is the
threat uh it best would be probably to
capture but even this would be very
difficult if King to C7 now Queen to F4
threatening E6 and there's just no good
way to handle this and you can't block
with the queen because just Rook
captures an F7 now if you capture again
check and you you blunder your queen so
after Rook the G7 Pro play Rook to f8
but now just Pawn to E6
um delivering a nice check King to C7
and now even Bishop to H5 you are never
worried about the the the pawn moving uh
so Queen to F6 attacking the rook and
not just Rook captures an F7 with check
Prague has to capture this root captures
e captures and now Rook the f8 going
after the pawn but now just Queen to E3
and uh there's no good way to to handle
this the problem is if you even if you
trade Queens let's say queen G5 you
force a queen trade uh how are you
stopping Rook d8 there is no good way to
stop this
uh if Rook D7 check you can even push
the king a little bit rook d8 and here
you resign either a queen is brought
into the game or you have to give up a
full Rook now a wrapper would be up a
full Rook so instead after Queen to E3
Rook captures and F7 was played Prague
decides to give up the exchange the
subcaptor's queen captures and now just
Queen to E7 with check here Robert
traits and here um a bit of a weird
thing happened this is move 39 a king to
B6 was played and that upward played
Pawn to C4 uh achieving move 40 so here
at Upward reaches time control he is
granted additional time but Prague
actually lost on time here he thought
that he was already on move 40 and his
time just dropped and here at airport
you know called The Arbiter he said okay
his time ran out and he was in this
position and move 40 that pregnant lost
on time but also there was nothing more
to be done here uh yes you are up to
pawns but there's no way for that Bishop
to get into the game if you if you play
something like Bishop to B8 just Rook to
F7 you're just gonna start gobbling up
pawns and if D5 you can even trade
captures captures Rook captures on F5
now this is hanging once you defend that
we're gonna go after the Rook here or
even Rook to F6 check let's take the B5
but now most certainly not Rook captures
on H6 if you play that then you blunder
the game Rook def or check picks up the
Rook so of course none of you were
considering that but of course King to
C2 you just move the king and you
capture the pawn on the next move uh
whatever black plays doesn't really
matter King to C4 you're gonna play Rook
characters on H6 let's say King Captain
D4 and it's a bishop and three pawns
against a rook and two pawns about let's
say Rook to B6 now you lose this Pawn as
well there's no way to save it uh
whatever you play uh still just equal
pawns and Rook versus Bishop completely
winning for white
uh so yeah after C4 Prague lost on time
and for those of you who are interested
in the standings after uh round eight
and this is prague's first loss in the
tournament so a very tough break for him
but these are the standings after eight
runs so the tournament is being led by
another Beck abdusattro with six
incredible points uh out of eight rounds
just a spectacular play uh followed by
second place Anish giver and Wesley so
with five points and with four and a
half points
you can see that it had Prague won this
game he would be in clear second Fabiano
caruana and the Magnus Carlson who after
two wins in a row climbs back up and now
he is again contending for for the top
three places it will be hard to catch up
to another back if he doesn't to lose
even a game but uh you know if if Magnus
continues winning anything is possible
then we have the World Chess
Championship Contender ding lyren uh not
doing all that great and 50 with four
points Erica Rapport and Parham aksulu
with three and a half with three euron
from forest and Arjun irrigation and in
last place not having the greatest
tournament Vincent kymer and the gookish
uh so yeah those were the standings hope
you enjoyed that as well uh we'll see
what happens today is the rest day so I
might check up on uh what's been
happening in the challengers as well if
you have any of your favorites do use
hashtag suggestion and I will uh go go
over that game so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it stop break for
Prague but a much needed win for rihad
Rapport I would like to thank Richard
Rob Victor David and Patrick for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Tata steel until it finishes uh thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day